[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up guys good to be here uh my
name is Hans and it's tough for me to
make friends with white people because
I'm gonna outlive them
we measure white people Asian dog ears
laughs
that's why my parents made me make
friends with white people early so I
could learn about death
play for the freedoms and talking back
to his parents
but yeah I'm doing pretty good I am
actually seeing a 24 year old woman
and uh I Can Tell She's 24 because
whenever I'm fingering her she's always
vaping
it's like why don't you vape my dick
[Applause]
I can make white stuff come out
thank you all right Hans Kim showing us
how it's done
Love The Vape joke got a little [__]
creepy after that but uh
I don't know if you need all that but uh
I love it how's it going Hans it's going
fantastically
um yeah I'm so wealthy right now it's
crazy oh you have been out there every
weekend Hans is absolutely killing it
all over selling out shows you were in
Tampa this weekend yes going
head-to-head with Uncle laser who
headlined a weekend there what was that
like it was like the nerd versus the guy
that has sex
that's true that's true you do have a
lot of sex no I'm kidding
uh that's fun so uh did you guys hang
out at all yeah I uh went to his pool
party he had a pool he had a pool party
in Tampa he was there one day he's
throwing pool parties
oh [__] oh [__] I think I hear the
rumbles of Uncle laser up there this is
incredible this is like when sting in
WCW used to sit up in the rafters and
watch the wrestling matches of the
people that he was gonna challenge later
on I remember it very well uh so um Hans
tell us more what else he was like dude
my fans are all hot girls and your fans
are all dorky losers how does that make
you feel he makes it feel like a little
little girl
okie dokie
[Music]
like what do you mean he makes you feel
like a little girl
he emasculates me he uh little Uncle
laser does yeah yeah Uncle Laser's an
alpha in this world over here
I love it you talked a lot of [__] about
outliving white people yeah sorry Tony
that's okay I forgive you it was good
this 24 year old is this new yes okay
where'd you meet her she came to one of
my shows here at the Vulcan and then she
gave me her number and told me she was
Jewish
ah and then I was like I'm in
okay what's the most Jewish thing about
her that you've noticed how long have
you been with her now I've been with her
four weeks okay yeah I thought so I
think I remember talking about a Jewish
girl with you but yeah tell me more
what's the most Jewish thing she wears a
mouth guard when she sleeps
the old [__] rape guard
so you don't go sticking your [__]
whatever in her mouth your little vape
pen you got down there
all right a mouth guard what else have
you noticed anything else uh she got
really mad at me yesterday because she
was licking my balls and I have really
sensitive balls it's not anything
personal and then she was like do you
think Uncle laser has sensitive balls
he hits those things with [__]
sledgehammers just to get him Juiced up
you know what I mean
oh [__] so you have sensitive balls and
then what happened was she trying to
like what was she doing the old matzo
balls or something like that I'm just
trying to spoon him into her mouth what
happened she was just uh tonguing them
with the tip of her tongue uh it felt
good I was it was just a little
sensitive
um and then I was like what do you say
when uh she tongues your balls too hard
is there a specific noise you make I was
like
laughs
oh Hans you are one of a kind now we all
know that you are famously Asian you are
uh South Korean yes and I want to ask
you about something because we found out
from the actual the actual news this
week that the uh coronavirus was
officially leaked out of a lab in China
I want to know because I can't speak
about it at all obviously I want to know
what your thoughts about that are uh you
know accidents happen
um
foreign
[Music]
you know when you're doing so much uh
research sometimes you make a couple
mistakes but you know at least we have
like Hello Kitty and uh
okay
Krista Stefano you've seen Hans before
right yeah I love Hans yeah I think uh
always always good and I'm happy that uh
you have a girl to lick your weather
balloons
[Laughter]
yes Radio City [__] musical here I
come
I love it yeah what else Hans anything
else before we let you go
um I've been seriously drone piloting
for a while now oh [__] pretty good
pilot
um piloting what drones oh drones nice
very North Korean of you
what have you been doing with these
drones tell us more I've been going up
to hotel rooms looking in
oh my goodness what a creep you are I
like it
they should have never gave you creeps
technology
why is your caller up right now oh
uh fashion
that is true he is somewhat fashionable
nice is that Amazon Classics what is
this yeah this is from Amazon I actually
have a couple hickeys oh let's see what
how many you think we should see those
hickeys here we go
here comes the Hans hickey reveal after
a long weekend in Tampa
supposedly as a girlfriend but wait
let's see
whoa dude you sure you didn't try to
hang yourself what's going on over there
dude
looks like [__] Epstein over here
it's just a playful accident
never an accident tell her to take out
her mouth guard next time
all right Hans another a great new
minute your fantastic consistent as it
gets what a lead off it or we couldn't
love you anymore you're out there you're
selling out we found you here [__]
June of 2021 you're killing it there he
goes hanzan
that was Hans Cam that was Hans Kim that
was Hans Kim to the bucket we go ladies
and gentlemen